holy crap it's Independence Day - I have
heard them talk about making an
Independence Day - for about 2 1 of
years now at a point I just stopped even
hoping for it now it's a movie that I'd
sod that now it has come to pass and it
gives us something to talk about
Independence Day resurgence so
Independence Day resurgence is a sequel
to the destructive alien invasion
disaster movie Independence Day this
one's also directed by Roland Emmerich
as the first one was and in this one the
aliens have returned in a much bigger
ship this thing is like bigger in
diameter than the United States of
America Jeff Goldblum's back Will Smith
is not little Pullman's back with his
new cast also I'm not even going to list
all of the cast is gonna take way too
long there are a lot of people whose
movie to a fault but basically we have
to now destroy this ship before it
destroys everything on earth okay so
alright Independence Day I remember
seeing in theaters I think I saw it like
four times it was just so cool when I
saw it and now in my adult world where I
review movies for a living if we're
being honest Independence Day is no
great movie it's an entertaining as hell
movie it's great destructive alien
invasion nonsense that you can kick your
feet back and just enjoy the destruction
as it's happening and that's all I
wanted for this movie but this movie
doesn't even have that luxuries just
sadly this movies pretty messy first of
all it takes about a half an hour for
anything to get going in this movie
that's being generous that's like the
fast estimate and I understand you need
to establish where the characters of old
from the first movie are now and where
these new characters came from but in
Independence Day one the first shot is
the ship going over the moon be lining
it to earth the invasion starts from the
first scene and this was just a lot of
talking and a here's our moon base
hey here's everything we did with the
technology hey this person's friends
with this person this person is dating
this person with this person used to be
friends with this person but they're not
friends anymore
look there are smoother ways to do this
in a movie I know it because I've seen
it to take Independence Day one they
establish all that [ __ ] after the
saucers actually come and start hovering
over the main cities like oh you need
the president you punched him it wasn't
the president then there's the whole
dating situation happening just could
have been smoother and there was no real
tension we know what's gonna happen in
the alien invasion cuz we saw
Independence Day won in the end this big
ship just comes out of nowhere it lands
on the earth that causes the destruction
I was just sitting there like a big
boring statue before I start hammering
this movie too much there are things I
like there were a couple of dogfight
ship scenes that I actually liked you
know when the fighter jet hybrids that
because we've blended our technology
with alien technology so now we have
like really cool Jets that almost look
alien our
fighting the little independent fighter
alien ships just like the first movie
it's entertaining in here only
difference is everything looks alien now
so you're like who am i rooting for
who'd alright just shoot [ __ ] and there
are so many characters in this movie
they want to give the old cast relevance
that want to give this new cast
relevance and you have too many irons in
the fire there is a scene where people
are talking about what's about to go
down everyone needs a reaction line of
some sort and I'm just like like
everyone just coming in like oh yeah I
think that's great yeah let's do that
oh man I'm scared alright I got your
back you ever have a group and everyone
is just trying to be the most relevant
one in the room what it look like it's
what it felt like it was pretty awkward
it had a point after like half the movie
is done these kids are driving down the
road and it was like more characters
you're introducing more now it wasn't
full before it did was brent Spiner is
back in this movie playing the same
character he played in the first
Independence Day movie we all thought he
was dead nope he was in a coma
what is he dr. drake ramoray or some
[ __ ] is this a soap opera what he was
dead no he was just in a coma for 20
years holy [ __ ] God like we're using
that and granted I like a reunion of the
old characters in the new movie as much
as the next guy but this one is just
like why was he even in this movie any
area51 lab tech guy could have actually
done what he did in this so you could
have just left a matter of whatever coma
it's like a coma is like a joke that
people use for a plotline like they did
in friends in the end of this movie
happens and it just kind of ends with a
whimper and then has this on the nose
set up for Independence Day 3 the only
thing missing was someone turning the
screen like yeah and I'll see you in
Independence Day 3 dananana and credit
some guys in the end Independence Day
resurgence felt like you know that
middle part of Independence Day we're
after the destruction before the end
fight everything kind of slows down it's
like that throughout a lot of this movie
it has an end fight but not a good and
fight like the stakes you don't feel
them this is the basic mindset that
bigger is better the Independence Day
one was a pretty simple movie pretty
simple premise the aliens invade they
kick our ass we try to retaliate it
doesn't work and there's some downtime
then we make our final stand and then we
win it allows them to keep it in the
pocket and it just keeps the movie fun
Independence Day resurgence tries to be
so much bigger and so much more than
that premise that it blows up in their
face and what they've made
is a pretty boring mess that looks like
it was being written as they were
filming the movie did you know a ship
landed after Independence Day one and
they were locked in a ground battle
between the aliens and African militia
did you know it happened I guess before
this movie took place they just kind of
fill us in and I'm still trying to
scrape for the relevance of that story
arc because I have no idea what it
played into this one in the end I'm just
gonna say Independence Day resurgence
I'm not gonna remember it in t-minus one
day I've already forgot [ __ ] I wanted to
like this one I did too but moving on I
want to hear what you guys think about
it so Independence Day resurgence have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more